Wonderful.
So I think we can get started.
David Tennenhouse, it is such an honor
to have you on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you, Michael.
Good to be here.
You know, I have your background
written down next to me
and I'm just overwhelmed
by attempting to start read it,
but I'll give a brief intro.
And I'd love to then dive
into your experiences.
So, Corporate Vice President
at incredible companies:
Intel, Amazon, Microsoft.
With a CEO of A9.com, subsidiary of Amazon.
DARPA's Chief Scientist.
Faculty member at MIT.
Partner at New Venture Partners.
VMware's Chief Research Officer.
LP at J-Ventures.
David, I only have 20 minutes.
I have to get as much knowledge
out of you as I can.
Did I get that right, first of all?
Was that okay?
You got that about right
Wonderful. Okay.
David, first of all, what does it mean
to be the chief research officer
of an incredible company like the VMware
which its foundation is based on research?
Well, the first thing is to be amazed that
people pay you to do this kind of thing.
I think, it is actually
just a phenomenal privilege.
You've got these really smart people
and a certain amount of it is just about
helping them find their way,
helping them connect
with business opportunities,
help them connect
with new research opportunities,
and really helping them get to the bottom
of how to maybe do more
with their great ideas.
Wow. Okay.
So, running chief research officer,
it sounds like it doesn't only entail
being the head scientist in the room
and choosing the path,
but it's also about culture.
It's about how do you drive innovation
and creativity within a group.
So, how do you drive innovation
and creativity in a world where VMware
is such a significant player
in distributed systems and the work that
I get to do on a day by day basis?
Well, the first thing to realize is,
people always talk about R&D.
I'm just the R, right?
But the D is the really big part of R&D.
So, a certain amount of this is still
about working with individuals
and as I said, helping them
take their great ideas.
So, it's really, I think you hit a stage
in your career where it's more, less
about driving your own ideas
and much more about
embracing other people's ideas
and really helping them drive them forward
and then sometimes standing back
and synthesizing them and say,
"Gee, you know, if we combine these ideas and
these ideas, maybe we can work on something bigger."
This is the challenge,
I think, in general,
in a research organization is that,
left to its own devices
you'll end up with many more
projects than you have people.
Wow. And how many researchers are there
at VMware as we're speaking now?
So, a certain amount there is
it depends how you count.
So, first off, you can't really say
researchers at VMware
'cause I'd say there are probably
many people in the company
that are actually conducting research
don't even know it.
Right.
But in terms of our corporate research,
it's actually a very small group.
So, think on the order of about
30 full time researchers.
We augment them.
We have postdocs.
We have interns.
So, when you said "right now" well
we have an enormous number of interns
working with both ...
... summertime.
We're in the peak of the intern season.
We have interns from all over the world.
This year, they're virtual -
I'm sure it's quite
an interesting experience
helping them, guiding them through this,
what is meant to be a very monumental
experience in their career.
Yup.
And then, and, so we augment.
The key is getting amplification.
So, we also actually have
a substantial number
of what we call affiliated ...
who are faculty members
that are working a day a week
roughly with VMware.
And some of these folks
have worked with us in the past.
So, for example, we have people
that came did a postdoc with us.
Now they're a faculty member.
They continue to work with us.
They send us interns.
So, we're not just working with them.
We're working with their team.
So, these are ways that you amplify
a research organization, right,
by adding in these these extra.
That's wonderful. My relationship
actually with VMware, it's funny.
Diane Green actually helped sponsor
a hackathon that I ran
when I was 18 in Silicon Valley
for young teens, 18 and under,
Hacking Generation Y.
One of my latest computer science professors
is Mendel Rosenblum, her husband.
So now we're speaking so I'm
getting to know more and more
of the VMware family,
which is wonderful.
But, David, I wanna take you back in time
and I want to now to have
a very selfish ask.
And I wanna talk about
young entrepreneurs like myself
and going through the incredible
experiences you've had from CEO of A9.com
to a partner at New Venture Partners,
to being a VP at three
magnificent corporations.
What major lessons can I take with me
as I'm just starting on my journey?
I'm just a baby here, right
24, I'm just now, I'm so curious.
What should I keep in mind as I go
through this journey and all of my friends
should keep in mind as well?
Well, I think there's a whole
bunch of things.
People will always say do the things
you're passionate about.
And they're right.
I mean, I think it's really
important to do that.
I think it's important, by the way to
about every five years,
stop and consider, right.
Is it time to make a change?
I think it's important to know yourself.
So there are people, by the way,
who are passionate about one topic
for decades.
They become the world's expert
in that topic
and they just keep going deeper
and their skill set is in that depth
and mastering that intricacy.
In fact, when I was in Intel we would have,
it was almost scary because
we had what we call the fellows
who were the experts
in any given technical area.
And what was scary was
you had this immense
many billion dollar company
with really the hero of lithography
The hero of how to design
the next transistor
The hero of how to take the things
from the lab into production.
But these people just
were really good at that.
So, that's knowing yourself
like maybe that's your thing.
For me, it's actually been
much more about hybridizing, right
So, in other words,
I love going into new areas.
Being a VC and you're getting
that experience now, right.
What's really neat is,
each company you go
it's likely that that company it's doing,
hopefully they're doing
something new and different, right?
So, you get to learn a new business.
Of course.
You've got to learn all about that
new vertical that they're in
and in fact, all the places they go
and that their customers are in.
So, I think knowing are you sort of one
of these people that's going to hybridize
across multiple places
and that's your strength,
I think of that as being
a portfolio person.
And I really came into that.
So, when I moved to DARPA,
I was then going from being sort of a
researcher at MIT with certain,
I won't say narrow,
because I was working across
what I thought
was a broad range of projects.
But now I have a big portfolio, right?
So, as a VC, it's more of a portfolio at,
or you can be the individual expert.
Both are great
but I think it's important to know
and there are a few people, not very many,
that can move between one and the other.
Right. Right so -
That's good, too,
but you need to know
which category you're in.
100%. And I think one of the interesting
challenges is that, at my age
when I'm just getting exposed to things.
My back story is that,
I grew up in a very tech savvy household.
My father has been in tech
for many many years.
And it took me a long time
to get into engineering.
And one of the things that he said
that really convinced me was,
"Michael, you can't assume your position
in the world before you experience
the different things.
So, go and learn engineering.
Go become good at artificial intelligence
and then decide what you wanna spend
the next 30 years on.
But you can't make a responsible decision
without actually trying
and giving yourself a fair shot"
But, David, I want to now take you back
and think what were some of the challenges
as a researcher early on in your career
that perhaps now are easier for you?
And if you were to go back to young David
and your various different positions,
what insights would you give yourself
to make the process a little bit easier
or more fulfilling?
Well, I think there's a couple
different things there.
I'd say is that I learned from one
of my mentors, George ...
a sort of list of standard questions
that he would ask, and unfortunately,
like I didn't learn this list.
So, you think, I started in Canada,
I did my graduate work in England.
Then I was at MIT.
Then only after that did I actually
pick up on this list.
It would have been good to know, and to start with
what are you trying to do?
So, again, it's a little different
from science
because scientists are trying to
ask a question almost of nature.
Engineers, we're trying to change the world.
We are trying to change something.
So, what are you trying to do?
Say it in really simple words.
Get it down to,
Google, they try to say it in five words.
But the important thing George said was,
be able to say it without a bunch of jargon.
And then he had this kind of neat question
which is, how do people do it today?
Now, that was kind of interesting because
here you think you're trying to do
anything new that nobody's done before
and you're gonna have this
whole new capability
and what he's saying is,
"Look, if this is really important,
people have worked out some way to do it.
They may be doing it manually.
They may be doing it through a crazy way.
But there's somebody out there
that has figured out some way to do it
and you need to understand
what that is"
So, you're replacing and displacing someone.
So, that's really kind of interesting.
Then, what's your new idea?
Really, how's your new approach?
How's it different?
And what are the three hard problems?
What are the, what I now call
when I talk to junior researchers,
what are the three rocks you need to move
in order to make this real?
And by the way, don't even try to move
all three of those
because maybe, this is again a lesson,
maybe if you move one of those rocks,
somebody else or something else will
move one or two of them in parallel.
So, but at least know what they are
because you don't wanna get to the end
and find that you got stuck
because it's something
that you should have anticipated.
So, now having learned about you're,
I've heard your story about your great
brilliant new idea and your new approach.
So, nobody's really followed
this approach before, you think.
And then his question was
why didn't it work last time?
Now, unfortunately,
the way he asked this question
tended to be very discouraging
but I've learned to try to be softer
in asking it.
Because what he's really saying is,
"Look, it's probably the case that somebody
tried something like this before."
You can get kind of get discouraged and say,
"Gee, damn, I thought this was
a whole new idea.
I only wanna work on whole new ideas.
I'm gonna have to go find something else."
What he was really saying was,
somebody has probably worked
on a variation of this.
Find it and understand why
it didn't work before.
And what I say to researchers is,
I trust your intuition.
In other words,
I believe that you are right,
that now is the right time to go try this.
Even if other people tried it
five years ago.
And others tried it 10 years ago.
And others tried it 15 years ago.
But what we need to figure out is
why your intuition is right
because probably what you're saying is
either the problem has changed,
and actually we're gonna apply
that idea from before
to a different problem
or somebody moved
one of those other rocks, right?
While we weren't looking.
Some other invention
has made this more feasible today.
Or something's changed
in the business climate
or in the business ecosystem.
But knowing why your intuition
is likely to be right
and that's something that
I wasn't as good at.
I think that I've always been
an intuitively driven researcher.
And it's important to know that,
first off 'cause it can guide your work
but second off, because it helps you
explain it to other people.
David, I think what I'm inspired
about here is this open mindedness
and curiosity that drives research that,
this whole time we haven't even mentioned
a single industry or a single problem
that you enjoy solving.
We're talking about the core of research
and finding opportunities and re-examining,
re-evaluating previous opportunities
that perhaps had those
big rocks stationed there.
And now, two years later,
something has changed.
Somebody moved a certain needle
that all of a sudden paved the way
and your role as a leader of a research team
is to be able to embrace that.
Trust your people's intuition
and help motivate them
to look for these new opportunities
that might not have been there before.
And by the way, when they go try
that new idea, that idea
that maybe people tried before
in these new circumstances,
by the time they're done,
it will be a new idea.
In other words, it will have morphed
and changed and they'll have added new insights.
So, it's not just a matter of
"The rest of our lives are just
re-creating ideas that some ancestors have"
It's this notion that as you go through it,
you're actually changing and gaining
more insight along the way.
And it's when you look back that you say,
"Oh, this is what was really important."
Anyway, you keep going
with your questions 'cause -
I have one that you probably
don't get that often,
but I'm still very curious.
Are there any regrets that you have
on things that you didn't do
in your career?
Because with such an impressive career,
I think it's very easy to go and say
he's done it all and he's completely
satisfied and fulfilled at doing everything
you wanted to do.
But are there certain positions
that you wish, that looking back
you might have wanted to take a stab at
or different entrepreneurial endeavors
you might have wanted to do?
No, I don't think in terms of,
this is a mindset
So I don't have regrets, right.
In that sense.
Would it have been nice to have had
a unicorn when I was a VC?
Sure. Of course.
That would have been great, right
I'm asking this because my generation
is all about FOMO.
And it's all about fear of missing out
on different opportunities
and grappling with the different things
that the world has.
And one of the things
that I wanna take with me is,
how do I go about my opportunities
not constantly thinking about
what else is out there for me.
I wanna be in the moment,
love what I do and concentrate on that.
Yeah. It's interesting.
This is a discussion I often have with people.
So, for example,
let's say I'm speaking to
a research candidate
and they've got offers from a university
and they've got offers from us
and they've got offers from another company.
I'm sort of like,
Hey, this is wonderful, right?
This is one of ... problems to have
is when you have these other opportunities.
So, I do get the sort of,
I can understand how people can
have the fear of missing out
and what I'd urge them to do
is just look at this as
what a great high class problem to have.
That you have all these different options.
Now, go get started on one.
Right.
When I was a researcher at MIT,
I remember being in a point where there
I was sort of spinning my wheels.
Because there were three different
major research initiatives
that I wanted to launch
and I loved all of them
And what I eventually had to do,
and I got some advice on this,
was just start one.
And in fact, the advice was,
"David, you have to let one of these things
trick you into falling in love with it"
I love that.
Let yourself get sucked into one of these
so that you throw your energy into it.
And I did that
And because I was just sort of almost
holding myself at a distance
from all three opportunities,
not diving in and committing to any one.
What was interesting was,
you know what?
A year later, we had that first
project up and running.
And an opportunity came by
to submit some proposals.
Yeah, you know we got the second one going.
Right.
And a couple of years later,
we got the third one going.
And so, when I looked a few years later,
I started them sequentially
but in fact, we actually had
I say we,
so it's myself, my graduate students,
people work ... me it was a a team.
So, it didn't matter which order.
It mattered to just let myself
get drawn into one of these enough.
Fall in love with them.
And not feel like you,
and this is again
a discussion I often have with researchers.
I'd say, "I'm not asking you
to let go of that other aspiration" right.
Keep it and love it.
Let's just get going with this one first
and then we're gonna get going
with the other one later.
I love that mindset.
I love that mindset of leadership.
And I love that mindset of fall in love
with what you do.
And it's not that you're foregoing
different opportunities.
You're choosing which ones to do now
and which ones to pursue later.
And you don't know what later
holds for you as well.
David, 20 minutes go by way too fast.
And I have to end with
my favorite question.
Three words that best describe you.
I guess one is a focus on impact.
Okay. Focus on impact.
Wanting to change the world.
This is in a good way.
A positive impact.
I know that's an extra word hyphenated.
I think this sense of being
a hybridizer or a tech polyglot -
I love that.
across different domains.
And then the other is is intuitive.
And I'm gonna confess that I'm not
as data driven as some people.
In other words, it's funny because
I champion data driven research.
I'm constantly trying to make our company
a more data driven company,
but I will say that in a lot of things
in research, I think it does
come down to intuition.
I love that so much.
David, thank you for the inspiration.
Thank you for the time to do this.
You have so much responsibility
and so many people that need you
and need your time.
So, I really thank you for being
so generous with me.
And good luck with everything.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you. Great being with you.
You stay healthy, too.
And just keep going with J-Ventures.
Thank you very much. Take care, David.
Bye bye. Bye bye.